asian markets spotted on tuesday as
investors feared the possible collapse
of chinese real estate giant everground
japan's nikkei opened after a market
holiday with a drop of almost two
percent
hong kong's hang sen was down 0.3 by
midday an 11-month low analysts expect
the chinese government to step in to
prevent the firm from defaulting on more
than 300 billion dollars worth of debt
but authorities have so far remained
silent if the chinese authority were to
actually allow evergreen to actually
default by itself that means allow
market action to actually uh dictate
without any intervention uh i would say
indirect intervention by the government
it will actually lead to a full-blown
localized crisis china's stock markets
remain closed for the mid-autumn
festival public holiday evergrand
chairman xujayin issued a letter to
staff saying he was confident the
company would walk out of its darkest
moment
he promised to deliver property projects
and fulfill responsibilities to buyers
investors partners and financial
institutions but he didn't say how
evergrand shares have plunged by 84 this
year on monday wall street marked its
biggest drop since may the value of
bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies has
also sunk
comparisons have been made to the levin
brothers the us investment bank that
collapsed and worsened the global
financial crisis of 2008
but some analysts say fears of contagion
are overblown at this moment it's a bit
overreacting
about some of the rumors that recently
uh we can we can see or or hear but uh
honestly speaking this is stock market
always
swing between um
like the sentiment at this moment i can
see it's i can conclude it's very
fragile
over the past year the chinese
government has tightened regulations to
reduce risks in the real estate market
economic growth remains sluggish due to
the pandemic
millions of investors vendors and
company employees are owed money by
evergrant beijing must walk a fine line
in responding to the crisis bailing out
the company completely may send out the
wrong signal and encourage businesses to
build up irresponsible debt but the
government doesn't want widespread
social unrest
katrina yu al jazeera beijing
gareth leather is a senior economist
with capital economics he's joining us
from london good to have you with us on
al jazeera what is it that the chinese
government could do if it wanted to in
order to try to slow this down or stop
it
yeah so they face a very difficult
bouncing act
on the one hand they don't want a
destabilizing collapse of everground
which causes problems for the wider
economy
but at the same time they're also
worried about moral hazard if they allow
a company such as overground which has
gorge itself on death and is in many
ways they're going to post the chart for
excess
in china's property market to carry on
functioning then it's only going to
encourage other property developers to
do the same
so it's got a very difficult bouncing
act to do over the next few weeks on how
to how to let this play out
the chinese government is
reputed to have significant contacts
with certainly some of the bigger
companies within within china is it a
surprise that this situation was allowed
to get to this stage
uh yes so in many ways this is being
seen as china's lehman brothers moment
it's kind of 13 years on since the
collapse of lehman brothers
and
i guess the advantage that the chinese
state has now compared to the u.s back
in 2008 is is seen what's happened if
you allow a big systemically important
financial institution to go bankrupt so
it's very unlikely that the chinese
government is going to let you know a
destabilizing collapse of ever ground
with kind of um contagion effects for
the rest of the economy so it's got a
difficult bouncing act on how this plays
out
one would imagine that this isn't going
to be restricted just to china of course
globally speaking who's most likely to
be affected by this
well it depends very much on on on how
far this goes if it's just contained
within china itself then i suspect what
you'll see is you'll see kind of further
fluctuations and pulls in prime stock
markets
but it will probably be limited to that
i think the kind of worst case scenario
is that if evergrand is allowed to
collapse and that confidence within
china's property sector as a whole
starts to get dented
then you could see a big sharp fall in
chinese property construction on the
theater called hard landing in which
case i suspect it will be big commodity
producers around the world now they're
mainly based in africa latin america and
australia that we hit quite hard it's
likely that some asian countries that
trade a lot with china as well would
also be be effective but i think the the
um the implications certainly for the us
and western europe and the uk would
probably be quite small
is this likely to be an isolated
incident do you think or could there be
other chinese companies that are in a
similar situation that we just kind of
haven't discovered yet
yeah so chinese data financial data is
murky at the best of times and it's very
likely that there are other financial
companies other sorry property companies
in china that have built up lots of
debts but everground is certainly the
worst one that we know about and it's
certainly suffering the biggest problems
at the moment i think the fear is that
if ever gone is alaska robust and
they're kind of destabilizing collapse
kind of way
that um that people will start
monitoring the health of other property
companies in china and you could see
more of these cascading over the next
few months
this is as you said before going to
even at this stage is going to put
forward significant certain concerns
about confidence in um certainly in the
chinese market in terms of of um
construction but also this could that
confidence or lack of it could spread
out through other elements of the
economy as well and we're not just
talking about banks we're not just
talking about big investors or pension
funds we're talking about individuals as
well because chinese people invest their
own money in companies like this
yes so i suspect it's very very unlikely
that you're going to see
people that have put down a big deposit
for homes with evergrand lose their
money i think they're going to be the
first port of call if the chinese
government is made to intervene in a big
way otherwise i suspect that the chinese
government the authorities will be quite
happy for some creditors to
to have a grant to take some losses as a
way of kind of taking some steam out of
the property market and also as well
we're teaching these investors that
there's a two-way street that they can't
but you know if you do have to have this
model hazard in place otherwise you know
people just sit as a one-way bet and
continue to embed on chinese property
really interesting to get your views on
this gareth leather is a senior
economist with capital economics and we
appreciate your time sir thank you very
much indeed
okay thank you